[Music]
hello everyone
uh so all this file we have been
talking about traction and we have
focused
in the last few uh lecture parts
on the stress tension and the various
components of the stressed insert
today we are going to start an entirely
new topic on
the normal and the shear components not
of the stress tensor
but of the traction vector itself so
and in the process we'll also see what
is the connection
with the stress tensor so in order to
keep things general what we'll do is
we'll take a a general plane
like this so
we take a general plane which is like
this please note that this is not a
three-dimensional body
so uh whenever i draw an arbitrary shape
or whenever i had drawn an arbitrary
shape till now
uh it had i had meant it to be a general
three-dimensional body
this is not a three dimensional body
this is a general plane
now the unit output normal to it would
be drawn
somewhat like this
so this is the unit outward normal to it
let's say this is the
n hat and
the traction vector originating from
this point itself
let that be like this
okay now
i would like to highlight at this point
in case
you haven't realized it yourself by now
is that the traction vector
this is the traction vector
this need not in general
be parallel to the unit outward normal
i'm sure most of you have realized it by
yourself
by now so we draw it in a different
direction
now what we say for the normal component
of the traction vector
is simply that you just take the
component of this vector
along this unit normal so usually we you
you take uh components of a
vector along unit direct along the
coordinate axis directions
and we can have coordinate axis
direction set up in this fashion
so let's say our coordinate axes are set
up like this
[Music]
let's say this is x1
x2
x3
but we do not wish to take the
components of this traction vector
along this x1 x2 or x3 what we wish to
do is we wish to take the component of
this fraction vector
along this unit outward normal
to this plane which is n hat okay
so the way that is denoted
is e superscript capital
n that is the uh that is the
representation we use
and you understand that will be simply
the traction vector
dotted with the unit outward normal as
simple as that
okay so that is all there is to the uh
to the normal component of traction
vector so this is what we refer to as
the normal component
[Music]
of the traction vector or
of t
so what about the shear component now
the moment we say shear
will our our visual understanding will
tell us
that it must be some component of the
traction vector
which is grazing along this surface
which is lying along this surface it's
like
grazing along that surface okay shearing
along that surface
now if this is the unit outward normal
then this traction vector
has a unique component
along this direction which is uh which
is represented by this t superscript
capital n
but the shear component it is not unique
because
you can take the component of this
fraction vector
along this direction and when i say this
direction i mean
a direction which is like this but lying
along the
plane itself or it could be along this
direction it could be along this
direction it could be all around this
point
but lying on that plane so which is
which is the shear component that we are
talking about are we talking about all
of them
at this point no we are talking about a
very very specific a very particular
kind of
shear component of the traction vector
so which one
so you see no matter how which way you
draw this traction vector
because you have two vectors here they
will be
they will be lying on a single plane
okay i am not talking about this plane
sorry about that
i'm not talking about this plane okay i
am talking about the plane
on which both this uh n hat
and the t vector will lie so please
remember
your your vector mathematics from your
high school
so we can understand that there will be
some plane like this
[Music]
which will be containing both the n hat
and the
[Music]
which will be containing both the n hat
and the t vector
now staying within this plane you can
understand
that there is only a single
direction which is this direction
along which you can take the component
of this
and that is the shear component we are
talking about
okay so what we'll say is
that uh
so the diagram is actually quite
it has come out to be nice because
this part lying on that plane
that itself is the shear component we
are talking about
and this thing okay so
let me just taken this
this this unit outward normally a little
bit
it will be still visible
[Music]
this is my unit output normal and
the
the yellow vector component here
this one that is my tn
[Music]
and this here that is my
ts
okay so
how do i represent ts so you understand
that
so let's say we use this color
okay so this will be some es
vector the
the ts
will be equal to t vector
dot es now you can take it as a little
exercise
to represent es
hat
as some combination okay so what is the
what is the representation of es
in terms of the
t vector and the n hat because
when you are when you were given the
situation
you only know about the t vector which
you are concerned with
and the unit outward normal which
defines this plane so you only know
these two things
so my question is how do you
connect these two
okay so this is just a simple exercise
in
in vector mathematics i'm sure you can
figure it out i will not spend any time
doing this so the hint is that you have
to take some cross products
okay now uh
what is interesting to note is
how does this representation turn out if
we
uh if we use the cautious formula of the
quotient's relation or the quotient
stress theorem
so just to recapitulate if we go back a
few slides
uh it is present here also so
this this thing uh this basically came
from the koji stress formula so if we
go back even more so this is the
original place where we talked about the
cautious
formula of the cauchy's law or relation
of stress theorem
and utilizing the symmetricity of the
stress sensor we could write it like
this
so what happens if we write this if we
use this
in our current form of the tn
so let me utilize this space here so tn
is equal to e vector dotted with
n hat so that is in terms of the stress
the stress tends to remind you so
[Music]
like this so this is the stress tensor
dotted with the n-hat this entire thing
dotted with the
n-hat okay so
uh what is
the the equivalent matrix representation
of
uh this normal component of the traction
vector
so it's very useful to to write it out
because
this is something this matrix
representation is something which you
can actually input
directly into some kind of uh
of a computer system like matlab or
python
and then can easily calculate the the
actual value of this
tm so what we can do is
for the equivalent matrix representation
we can write it like
so
so t vector dotted with the
n so this thing
this entire matrix representation would
be
vector
transpose so please note that this is a
little bit of a confusion here
i am using the symbol t for the
transpose
okay but i hope it will be clear
okay so what i'm basically using here is
that if you have
a vector dotted with b vector the the
equivalent matrix representation of it
is a vector
uh transpose b vector
okay it is very important to use this
transpose otherwise you'll have a
mismatch in the way the matrix
multiplication has to be carried out
okay i'll raise this part
now the t vector itself
that is the
sigma transpose dotted with n
so the transpose of this okay
[Music]
so this will be
[Music]
sigma transpose
[Music]
[Music]
enhanced
transpose of this entire thing because
this transpose is coming from here
and hat and finally
what we'll have is so this is like a b
transpose
so that will be b transpose a transpose
so that will be ultimately in transpose
[Music]
so if we go to the next slide
we can quickly summarize what we have
just found
that tn is equal to
this one sigma transpose dotted with n
so this is the compact notation
that dotted with n hat and this entire
thing
is equivalent to innate matrix
representation to this thing
so uh i sorry i missed the transpose
here
because this is a sigma transpose n
uh entire thing transpose so this should
be
n transpose sigma n so i believe it will
be
uh clear to all of you here so this is n
transpose
sigma
n
uh
you also note that
we have this relation to be true so
ts
[Music]
square that should be equal
to t vector
take the magnitude of that square that
and then t n
square so basically what we are doing is
we are utilizing uh the fact
that the tn the ts and the t vector
geometrically they make up the
right angle triangle so basically we're
using a
particular pythagoras theorem to write
this as
t s square plus t n square is equal to
magnitude of
the t vector square and that's what i
have written here
[Music]
you also note that
[Music]
the following must be true that
the t vector is simply equal to
the tn
n hat plus ts
this is very simple to understand so i'm
just writing some basic truths
in front of you uh
furthermore another really very useful
relation to note
uh is
the ts written in terms of
the stress component so ts
we have already seen is equal to
e vector dotted with es
now the equivalent matrix representation
let's write it here would be
[Music]
a vector transpose
is vector and
that is equal to just like before
sigma transpose dotted with
n hat then that thing transpose
yes and that
[Music]
n hat the matrix representation of that
transpose
[Music]
sigma tensor
yes hat okay
so please note the similarity of this
particular form that i have just written
with this font okay so the first two
parts they are the same
it is only in the last part where the
difference is
and that is that is of course coming
from the fact that this is the no
this is along the normal component and
this is along is the shear component
okay now all this while we have been
talking about the
es vector the very particular
shear direction what about another
shear direction so suppose we do not
limit
ourselves uh to be lying within this
plane that is
um that contains the t vector and the n
n hat suppose we are not no longer
restricted to
this to this particular plane then you
can very well
have a
a a direction
somewhat like this some general
direction like this
which is of course lying again on that
plane
and let's say we call that as the unit
vector along that
to be e t so
[Music]
so no problem we can have
a component along that direction
just like this all that you have to do
is take the traction vector dotted with
the
ep vector of course we have to know
specifically about
which et we are interested in
now
it is very interesting to think
of these representations to be some sort
of a
of a gateway towards a better
understanding of the
stress components so what i mean to say
is that
suppose we have taken this kind
of a very general plane which is lying
obliquely to all the coordinate axis
but suppose suppose we we chose
this plane to be perpendicular
to the x1 axis then surely
the unit outward normal to it would be
along
the e1 vector that is along the x1
direction
i repeat suppose we had chosen this
plane not to be lying along this some
arbitrary direction
uh rather it was a plane which was
which is parallel to the x2 x3 plane or
equivalently perpendicular to the x1
axis
in that case the n-hat would be nothing
but
the e1 vector the e1 hat the e1 hat
is the is the unit outward is the unit
normal along the x1 direction
then you see what happens then
this normal component of the traction
vector what does it become you put e1
here you put e1 here
okay then what what what what really
happens
so you can do this little exercise
actually it's very interesting
so uh
suppose
n hat is equivalent to e
1 e 1 hat okay and what is e 1 hat
the equivalent matrix representation of
it
so we can of course write it with a
bracket here but
what i mean to say is that what is the
actual
uh what are the actual components of it
in in matrix form
so we have to write it like a column
matrix
and that column matrix is going to have
three components the first component is
going to be one
the second component is going to be zero
and the third component is going to be
zero
similarly if you had taken the this to
be
the e 2 hat it would have been 0 1 0 and
the e 3 hat would have been 0 0
1 now we are only concerned about e 1
hat
in there in that case okay in that case
what would be our t n it would be
so if we use this formula
it would be e1 hat
transpose sigma
e1 hat and what is that
it's very simple well you just write it
so this is the transpose so i have to
from a column pick from the column
matrix i have to
make it to a row matrix so it becomes
like this
the sigma
matrix is sigma 1 2 sigma 1 3
sigma 1 2 again sigma 2 2
sigma 2 3 sigma
sigma 1 3 sigma 2 3 again
and sigma 33 so i'm writing this out in
detail just for
the ease of your understanding uh every
time you do not have to
write the whole thing so if you
if you do the actual multiplication what
it will come out to be
is just this you can check for yourself
okay you can actually check for yourself
so
uh and this gives us a clue actually
uh about the physical interpretation of
the geometrical interpretation of the
various components of the stress
so see
the sigma 1 1 from this what we are
concluding is that the sigma 1
1 is nothing but the normal
component of the traction vector
on a plane which is perpendicular to the
x1 axis it's as simple as that you
you actually know all of this stuff from
your first year mechanics
now what about the sigma one two you see
there are two different indices here
so of course we cannot uh we cannot be
using this normal component and you know
that this is uh the shear component
so uh for that shear component what you
have to do is
uh you can take so you can
think of of a generic shear component
not not necessarily this particular
shear component
so what you can
do is you can consider a
let me go to the next slide
so to interpret
sigma 1 to let's say only sigma 1 2
you can take the normal component
to be the e1
so that you will have the equivalent
matrix representation as 1 0 0
and the e t hat
okay mind you i am no longer taking the
e s hat i'm taking the e t hat
that will be e 2 hat
and that will be 0 1 0
ok so what i'm doing is instead of this
this generic t or the specific ts
i am taking the uh
a general uh shear component
of the traction vector so
i can actually make a i can note here
that
some
that will be nothing but
where if we go back to the previous
slide
you understand that the e t hat it lies
along the plane
but it is different from e s that is all
there is to it
okay so this is some general shear
component
so coming back to this interpretation of
sigma 1
2 if you take the n hat along 1 e 1
and the e t hat along the e 2 which is
the 0 1 0
then what you will obtain for the
shear component t t that is
n hat transpose
sigma
[Music]
uh a t hat and that will be nothing but
e one transpose
e2
all right so from here you will end up
with
this is equal to sigma 1 2
okay so you do it the other way around
you will end up with
again sigma 1 2 because
this stress tensor is actually symmetric
so it'll it's a little fun exercise to
do these little calculations and
convince yourself
that what you are expecting it to be
true mathematically from your actual
calculation also it comes out to be
true all right so you can go about
doing all these little fun things but
as far as the as uh as far as the topic
is concerned
we are we have completed it and uh
in the next part of the lecture what
we'll do is
we will utilize the concepts that we
have developed here particularly in
connection with the normal component
of the traction vector
to develop our ideas towards the
calculation
of the extremely extremely important
topic
of principal stresses so we are building
it step by step
so first we discussed generally about
traction then we talked about stress
components
in this part part of the lecture we
talked about the normal and the shear
components of fraction
and then we are going to build on the
normal component of the traction vector
to towards the idea of principal
stresses and you'll see that
the the similarities and some
differences
with the idea of principle streams that
we studied in the previous chapter
all right thank you very much